no matter who you are we all have
somebody in our lives that tells us
competing is a terrible thing it's not
good to compete honey it's too much
pressure when you compete sweetheart
it's not good to compete because
someone's got to lose anyone who ever
said that anybody who ever said that now
watches sports now watches TV that goes
to restaurants and post reviews on Yelp
anybody who says something like that yet
does that they're contradicting
themselves here's why everything great
that ever happened is stemmed from
competition everything world peace does
not exist it just does not exist
competition is one of the best things
that you see in business sports anything
and by the way typically those who make
it to the highest ranks in sports in
business and life in entrepreneurship in
anything they're typically the most
competitive if you can ever meet in your
life so today I will talk about ten
reasons why to compete not ten benefits
of competing ten reasons why to compete
I'll go through a fairly quickly first
one I think competition brings out the
best in you when you're competing
especially if you go against somebody
that is 10 times better than you you all
over some like wait a minute
I am not as good as I thought I was I'm
gonna have to learn to fight so I'm
gonna have to learn to pick my game up I
cannot believe how much faster he's deme
I cannot believe how better they are at
customer service than us I cannot
believe how amazing they are with their
systems and their comp we're going to
compete with these guys oh my god we we
got to figure out a way to get better so
it brings out the best in you when
you're competing number two pain of
losing is a great motivator pain of
losing is one of the greatest motivators
of a competitor let me explain something
to you the same people that say
competition is not good for you I
guarantee you if you sit down and have a
private conversation with them and
they're willing to be open there was a
very painful loss at some point of their
lives what could it be they lost the
girl to another man they lost a man to
another girl that hurt them they lost a
customer to somebody they lost a game
someone beat them in a public event at
sporting event they didn't like that
they lost in a debate publicly they
completely stumbled once and instead of
getting up and wanted to compete again
which we've all had our embarrassing
moments in our lives they chose to let
that define them they chose to let that
define them
anybody that competes at the highest
level they had a very painful loss very
painful loss I remember I can tell you
have won you know in business for the
last 15 years I've won many many times
but I can tell you the ones I remember
vividly or my losses and the ones that
got me to step up look at myself in the
mirror dust myself off and say man that
hurt
that's what caused me to compete and get
better and improve my business to the
next level
number three competition keeps you young
believe it or not those who are engage
in the game they're younger because
they're not rusting out somehow nada man
what if I burn out I would definitely
rather burn out than rust out I
definitely rather be in the game I'm
like man let's go let's go let's get
them that then sit around and just watch
everything rust out and not be in the
engage in competing I would rather see
that happen any day of the week so
competition keeps you young you got to
stay young because in order to keep up
with everybody else you're kind of gonna
end up staying young number four this
strategy from your problems in your life
if you think about the last time you
really dwell into problems so deep that
it almost drove you nuts
I can I can tell you at least for myself
anytime I go so deep into a problem that
it makes me what if this why don't you
wanna say devoted that it's when I have
when I have so much time on my hands and
I'm not in the hunt for something
because when you're in the hunt for
something when you're competing for
something when you're improving to do
something you don't have time to think
about prompts you actually have a
positive distraction everyone in life as
distractions everybody a kid could be a
positive distraction to a business a
business could be a positive distraction
to an ex-girlfriend a there are a lot of
positive distractions
competition is a positive distraction
and it takes you into the
so much so you don't have time to be
thinking about all the problems and all
the possibilities of the world coming to
an end you don't have time for that
because you're engaged you're in the
arena competing number five believe it
or not when you compete you build new
relationships and somebody would say
wait a minute when you compete you build
new relationships yes let me explain to
you the simplest way let's just say
you're a kid that plays tennis
hypothetically so you start playing
tennis with your dad Canyon you're
pretty good Mary you play with your dad
I'm actually pretty good then you stop
playing with your brother and you're
actually you beat your brother and
that's your older brother by two years
and you've been um in tennis okay cool
so everybody so far you know is who
family then your dad and your mom say
why don't we put you in a different
place where you start competing get some
coaching and they start getting a coach
and your backhand is good your you know
your service good you you're out your
footwork skinning good they're the
coaches you know what I think we should
put on the league and then going to a
league you're not in high school this
year twelve thirteen years old you going
to a league and in the league you start
doing good and in all of a sudden you
beat a couple guys and then you get beat
once by somebody that's very good she is
ten times better than your look oh my
gosh and the next thing you know you win
one where you go into a tournament and
there's thirty girls that are not
competing you officially build new
relationships with dirty new competitors
and you're one of them now you have no
relationships if you're in the business
world and say your social media
consultant you have to go to all the
social media conventions you have to go
to all the social media events to find
out what all the up-and-coming things
are that's coming up if you don't go to
it you being left behind you're not a
competitor what if you don't do it if
you don't do it you know nothing about
snapchat you know nothing about the new
anchor music all this stuff that's
changed you don't know about it so
you're not a competitor you being lefty
I know is gonna argue because you don't
know what's up to date because you're
not a competitor but if you go to all
these functions all of a sudden people
going to know they know what you're
talking about now you're part of a
committee of ten other competitors that
are fighting to get the same customers
you're going for but you're learning how
to get better because you're amongst
these other competitors you build a lot
of relationships if you do compete
number six I was at a convention this
past week in Palm Springs had a great
time there was a lot of energy this
place has thirteen fourteen hundred
people at this convention of
Springs and I watch everybody i watch
everybody and one of the things I pay
very close attention to there are those
that are established let's just say in
business but then there are those that
are young and hungry and coming up in
business not age they're young in
business they're not necessarily err
there could be 42 years old but they're
young in business right and you see the
look on their eyes this competitor and
you see somebody that's established
their eyes are a little droopy they've
lost a fire right and this other
person's coming up and you're trying to
do whatever they can but they keep
losing keep losing keep losing but
they're not giving up let me tell you
something these guys aren't a lot of
respect they get respect from everybody
because it's kind of like in school when
you fight somebody and you beat this
person up but this person swings back
every time you find him even you beat
him you don't want to fight this person
mix up he's like this and at least this
person I fight he never swings this
person I fight
he won't stop swinging until I kick his
butt and he typically gets me a couple
times I don't want to fight this guy
gained respect even though this person
lost there's a lot of respect for
competitor there's a lot of respect for
somebody that goes to the last minute
and fight to the very last minute even
if they lose in sports you hear Nathalie
saying you know these guys were a tough
tough person we face this was not an
easy one this was they fought till the
very last minute and you'll see some
time where there's all these guys gave
up after the first game because I lost
by 28 points that's no respect you don't
gain respect with that number seven
number seven is when you're a competitor
one of the reasons when you compete your
brain gets wired in improvement mode
your brain gets right an improvement
moon let's just say you run a real
estate business and you lost one your
clients and they want to change your
listing and to put it with another than
why and you found that the reason why
they did would do this other guys
because that guy has five people that
are passing out flyers and that guy is
got is got people that are doing all
these are the marketing for him and he's
got it on five different website and
it's putting on craigslist and you
didn't do that well guess what if you
want to compete with this guy do not
lose future listings
you better improve if you don't get out
of the real estate business you're going
to lose some every
time if you run a coffee shop and
there's a coffee shop across the street
customers used to come to you that
they're no longer coming to you they're
going to cross the street that customer
kept telling you hey with this coffee
why don't you have some sweet for us to
have and you said no our specialty is
mainly coffee now you lost that business
that's going to cross the street now you
may want to consider having some kind of
sweets you know they can you put some
shares outside so we can sit outside I
don't want to sit inside the weather
sometimes good I just want to sit
outside no we're only in inside cafe you
got to figure out a way to go a little
bit outside because you got to figure
out ways to improve our owner who's the
customers to the guys across the street
when you are a competitor you're
constantly going to be in the mode of
improvement because someone's constant
going to be beating you and by the way
to those of you that are watching this
that you're not choosing to be
competitive guess what when businesses
compete guess who it serves you and I
when restaurants compete at serves you
and I when movie theaters compete it
serves you and I when universities
compete ibly serves you and I because
they're trying to make it better I was
at USC meeting with the president of USC
were sitting there he invited 13
different people at this tables and
they're having lunch together and he
starts talking about how their goal is
to raise 6 billion dollars and we ask
what are you raising six billion dollars
for he says we're building a cafeteria
it's a one and a half billion dollar
project and we're building a cafeteria
identical from the Harry Potter movie no
way yes why because they want their kids
to want to go to USC because these kids
are accustomed to watching Harry Potter
they want to be able to say our
cafeterias cool because they're
listening because the one school he
mentioned the entire time we were ready
sitting there was who Harvard USC wants
to compete with Harvard think about that
that's impressive if I got kids I want
to go to a school and I know a guy like
that is competing at Harvard I'm
interested in that because they want to
make the school better for our kids
competition number eight
fulfillment there's a lot of excitement
of fulfillment when you compete there's
certain excitement you get when you
compete I can't describe it to you when
people are the arena competing there's a
certain sense of fulfillment
there's a lot of people right now I said
did you see that picture with Michael
Phelps he's swimming and the other guy's
looking at him man that guy's a loser
that's why you focus on winners I'm
sorry he's in the Olympics he made it to
the Olympics that's pretty epic
I shared a picture myself but that guy's
in the Olympics he's fulfilled man he's
gonna say I was an Olympian now
obviously there's a there's a very small
community of great ones but at least he
went and he made it to compete with the
great one even though the world's gonna
say he lost to his family his an
Olympian for his kid he's always going
to say daddy was an Olympian daddy was
an Olympian that it was an Olympian the
girl the gymnast that lost the other
girl was just an absolute beast by two
points which is just incredible point
should be she says she's gonna be an
Olympian for the racer kids are gonna be
very proud to have mommy be the girl
that she is fulfillment there's a lot of
fulfillment when you compete number nine
when you compete you attract a lot of
other opportunities I was having a
meeting with our staff and I said listen
um if you work at our home office and
you work with me and your competitor and
you're all about improvement pushing a
little bit more than the rest you're
guaranteed to move up if you work with
me because to me competitive people are
very valuable because you always want to
move up they always want to make things
better they always want to figure out
what to do it faster or better I love
having people on the team that are like
that I love having people that'll come
if they're not I simply say we're not
the company for you but if you are we
are the company for you so other
opportunities come from people like this
other opportunities come out of nowhere
from people like this I was talking to
one of our guys we were driving to Fort
Worth today me and tigran and he started
asking me questions about himself on all
this others I said listen let's face him
when you first got started with me I was
about to fire you he says I remember
that sir but there's one thing that you
got you respond
I said you respond I give you one
challenge and it was your last challenge
in my mind I had already given up on you
but I said I was so impressed with the
way you came back and you proved me
wrong and you came in boom you responded
it showed me your competitor you want to
be one of the best his department the
company is probably doing better than
any other departments in the company
because he's competitive because he's
competitive okay so he got other
opportunities he went from just having a
regular position to
a bigger position with the company
that's in you know involved in a
leadership types of meetings that we
have our software he's going and
visiting all these other offices across
the country and last but not least if
you choose to compete one of the reasons
to compete you eventually not
competitors or workers just to keep them
I'm not saying you want to compete or
you don't want to work if you choose to
compete one of the reasons to compete
you eventually end up beating ninety
five percent of your competitors
ninety-five percent of your competitors
you end up beating ninety five percent
of your competitors you end up beating
if you keep consistently wanted to
compete anybody that at one point was
your competitor if you can't stay keep
competing eventually you find yourself
only competing with the five percent and
the five percent to be the best that the
five percent is a dog fight it's ours
it's even improving faster it's being
able to recruit the right talent being
part of right team and having a vision
of where you're going being clean on you
know then you've been it's a real
dogfight so those are the ten reasons to
compete if you got any questions or
comments or thoughts post your comments
on the bottom by the way we are trying
to get two hundred thousand subs we have
a goal of getting to a hundred thousand
subs by the end of the month so please
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
please do so and if you already have
subscribed to the channel share this
content with other people we believe
this is the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurship you asked
the question you request the videos
we'll put it on our calendar and if it's
something that's suitable to us we'll
post a video to answer your questions
for you but would that being said if you
watch this video this video is typically
get stolen put on different channels and
websites you can always come back to
Patrick video be calm oh and find a ton
of the content there thanks for watching
everybody
take care
you